You're just such a polished, off-the-cuff. Did Bryce prepare for any of this? It's, it's, I don't have an off mode. I don't have an off switch for this. It's just, I just wake up in the morning and I'm just in politician mode. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 61, recorded on January 8th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we cover part one of our 2021 retrospective. All right, let's do the retro. Retro, episode 61, 2021, go. Top three? We'll do the retro. Retro. Episode 61. 2021. Go. Top three.
你真是太圆滑、太即兴了。Bryce 为这一切做过准备吗？我没有“关闭”模式。我没有这方面的关闭开关。我早上醒来就直接进入了政客模式。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 61 期，录制于 2022 年 1 月 8 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，探讨我们 2021 年回顾的第一部分。好了，我们开始回顾吧。回顾，第 61 期，2021 年，开始。前三名？我们做个回顾吧。回顾。第 61 期。2021 年。开始。前三名。
We'll do top three. Top three highlights of the year. Or if you want to just give a little 2021 in review first from either Bryce's personal view or Bryce Library Evolution Working Group chair view, or what are you? Architect? HPC architect? Head of CCCL? You've got like a bunch of different hats
我们来聊聊前三名。今年表现最突出的前三名。或者如果你想先从布莱斯个人视角，或是布莱斯图书馆演进工作组（Library Evolution Working Group）主席视角，亦或是你的其他身份——建筑师？HPC 建筑师？CCCL 负责人？你有很多不同的头衔
feel free to give a an amalgamation me like you know i moved to new york which was like a very substantial part of my year so that was uh that was sort of a big deal and that consumed like a whole chunk of my time um i guess you would already when did you move back to toronto i moved back in uh nove of 2019, approximately three or four months before the pandemic. Yeah. So you were, you were already gone, but so, so I moved to the, moved to New York. I mean, I think we've done, you know, we, we really sort of finished the C++23 design cycle in 2021. You know, we have like a few weeks left to be design complete,
你可以把它们综合起来说说，比如你知道的，我搬到了纽约，这对我来说是非常重要的一部分，所以这算是一件大事，占了我很大一部分时间，嗯，我想你大概会问，你是什么时候搬回多伦多的？我在 2019 年 11 月左右搬回来的，大约在疫情爆发前三四个月。是的。所以你当时已经不在了，不过，所以，我搬到了，搬到了纽约。我的意思是，我觉得我们已经，你知道的，我们确实在 2021 年完成了 C++23 的设计周期，你知道的，距离设计定型只剩几周时间了，
but most of the actual substantial work that happened for C++23 wrapped up this year. And I think that C++23 is pretty exciting. I think we've got some pretty exciting work coming. Yeah, I think it's shaping up to be a pretty interesting release. Ranges, woo! Yeah, there's a lot of ranges enhancements. Standard library modules stood expected.
但为 C++23 所做的大部分实质性工作都在今年完成了。而且我认为 C++23 非常令人兴奋。我认为我们有一些非常令人兴奋的工作即将推出。是的，我认为它正逐渐成为一个非常有趣的发布版本。Ranges（范围），呜呼！是的，有很多关于 ranges 的增强功能。标准库模块（modules）、std::expected。
Deducing this. There's a variety of other language enhancements. Extended floating point, something near and dear to my heart. MD span. And the jury is still very much out on what's going to happen with executors. Stay tuned for that. We'll find out soonish yeah there was a a fireside committee panel chats that i watched on youtube that took place in september and you were i i mean i'm biased because you're my podcast co-host
Deducing this。还有各种其他的语言增强功能。扩展浮点数，这对我来说是一个非常亲近且亲爱的话题。MD span。至于 executors（执行器）会发生什么，目前还很难说，大家拭目以待吧。我们很快就会知道了，嗯，我在 YouTube 上看过一个委员会的炉边座谈小组聊天，那是九月份进行的，而你——我的意思是，我带有偏见，因为你是我的播客联合主持
and colleague and friend but i think you were sorely missed because at one point there was a question about you know what is there to look forward to in c++ 23? And the answer was very limited. See, I find it a little bit, I think it's a little bit hard to have a C++ committee fireside chat where almost none of the people on the chat are actually actively participating in the committee so um that might perhaps explain why people were unable to coherently answer why i mean at least at least a few of the people on stage were but a couple were but there were also a number of prominent people on the panel who are not actively participating in the standardization process that's that's that's that's all i'm going to say that i think if you're
同事兼朋友，但我认为大家真的很想念你，因为当时有一个问题是，关于 C++23 中有什么值得期待的？而答案非常有限。你看，我觉得，举办一个 C++ 委员会的炉边座谈会，而座谈会上几乎没有人真正积极参与委员会的工作，这有点困难，所以这或许可以解释为什么人们无法连贯地回答为什么——我的意思是，至少台上少数人是可以的，但有几个人不行，不过座谈会上也有好几位知名人士并不积极参与标准化进程，这就是我要说的全部内容，我认为如果你要
going to have a panel of people talking about a thing, those people should actually be qualified to talk about the thing. And not everybody on that panel was qualified to talk about the things. So maybe they should have kept their mouth shut. All right. This is juicy content for the ADSP listener. Yeah. But yes, C++23. I do. I mean, there's lots of range of stuff getting in.
组织一个小组来谈论某件事情，这些人实际上应该有资格谈论这件事。并不是小组里的每个人都有资格谈论这些事情。所以也许他们应该闭嘴。好吧。这对 ADSP 的听众来说是很有料的内容。是的。但是没错，C++23。我确实——我的意思是，有很多 ranges 的东西正在加入进来。
There's a bunch of talks that I'm looking forward to giving at Jason Transform. I'm excited about Cartesian product. The thing I'm actually probably most excited about is that you can now write your own pipeable range adapters so that anything that we forgot to add as a range adapter,
我有很多期待在 Jason Transform 上发表的演讲。我对笛卡尔积（Cartesian product）感到很兴奋。我实际上可能最兴奋的事情是，你现在可以编写自己的可管道化范围适配器（pipeable range adapters），这样任何我们忘记添加为范围适配器的东西，
you can now add yourself. So I think that's pretty cool. Yeah, you can use other... So you can basically use range V3 with the standard out standard ranges as well i actually i use yeah adjacent transform is pretty cool i used it the other day when i was writing an example um i've been using repeat a bit um i've been the whole window and that family of ones. Oh, yeah.
你现在都可以自己添加了。所以我觉得这挺酷的。是的，你可以使用其他……所以你基本上也可以将 range V3 与标准的 std::ranges 一起使用。我确实用过，Jason Transform 挺酷的。我前几天写一个示例时就用到了它，我一直在用 repeat，我一直在用整个 window 及其相关系列的函数。哦，是的。
Window and chunk and whatnot. Anamorphisms, unfolds. Yeah, slide, chunk, et cetera. Those are all pretty cool. I haven't quite figured out how to do all the exciting things that I want with them, but I wrote some pretty cool examples combining cartesian product and slide and chunk of building like um decomposing a multi-dimensional space into like tiles um i haven't like i don't think that it's quite the right way to do it but i was able to do some cool little things with it i think i showed
Window、chunk 之类的。Anamorphisms（anamorphisms）、unfolds。是的，slide、chunk 等等。这些都很酷。我还没完全弄清楚如何用它们做出我想要的所有精彩效果，但我写了一些非常酷的示例，结合了笛卡尔积（cartesian product）、slide 和 chunk，用来构建，比如将多维空间分解成图块之类的，我还没觉得这完全是正确做法，但我能够用它做一些很酷的小东西，我想我向你展示过其中的一些示例，
you some examples of that yeah yeah yeah i will this is a random, a random side note, but that the fact that you mentioned sort of unfolds and anamorphisms. I was just watching a Haskell keynote from Haskell Exchange 2021 by Nadia Polakopova. But she meant she showed it's an awesome keynote is the point. And she talks about Hoogle and a variation on Hoogle called Hoogle Plus, which I actually already had taken that name for a website that I haven't created yet. Perhaps you should remind people what Hoogle is, and then you can tell people what Hoogle Plus is. We'll save that for another episode. We'll save that for another episode. But the point is that she talks about group, which is another example of an unfold or an anamorphism similar to chunks of
是的，是的。我有一个随机的题外话，但既然你提到了 unfolds 和 anamorphisms。我刚才正在看 Nadia Polakopova 在 Haskell Exchange 2021 上的 Haskell 主题演讲。但她的意思是——她展示了一个很棒的主题演讲，这就是重点。她谈到了 Hoogle 以及 Hoogle 的一个变体叫 Hoogle Plus，其实我以前已经把这个名字留给了一个我还没创建的网站。也许你应该先提醒大家什么是 Hoogle，然后再告诉大家什么是 Hoogle Plus。我们留到另一期节目再讲吧。我们留到另一期节目再讲吧。但重点是她谈到了 group，这是 unfold 或 anamorphism 的另一个例子，类似于 chunks 和 slide。无论如何，C++23，我认为有很多让人兴奋的地方。很明显它比 C++20 小得多，但是话说回来，回到 2021 年的回顾。还有什么？这对你来说是前三名的事情吗？对我来说，我的意思是，我把很多时间花在让委员会推动各项工作上。所以，是的。
and slide. Anyway, C++23, I think there's lots to be excited about. Obviously it's much smaller than C++20, but yes, back to 2021 retro. What else? Is that a top three thing for you? For me, I mean, like I spend like a lot of my time keeping the committee doing things. So yes.
然后继续。不管怎样，C++23，我认为有很多让人兴奋的地方。显然它比C++20小得多，但是是的，回到2021年的回顾。还有什么？对你来说这是前三的事情吗？对我来说，我的意思是，我花了很多时间让委员会做事情。所以是的。
And let's see, what other stuff? I mean, my team at NVIDIA, yeah, my team at NVIDIA has done a whole bunch of, you know, super awesome stuff in the past year. Almost none of which I can claim any credit for other than standing around and promoting it. But yeah, it was a huge year for us. The team doubled in size.
还有，看看还有什么？我的意思是，我在英伟达（NVIDIA）的团队，是的，我在英伟达的团队在过去一年里做了大量超级棒的事情，除了站在旁边为他们宣传之外，几乎没有一件事情我可以居功至伟。但是，是的，对我们来说这是巨大的一年。团队规模扩大了一倍。
Obviously, Eric Neva came and joined our team, which is super exciting. Yeah, there's just so much stuff that we've gotten done the past year, both in our C++ core libraries and also in our NVC++ compiler. And I think the future is very bright for both of those things. I'm looking forward to what we'll be able to do next year.
显然，埃里克·内瓦（Eric Niebler）加入了我们的团队，这超级令人兴奋。是的，在过去的一年里，我们在 C++ 核心库和 NVC++ 编译器中完成了太多的工作。我认为这两者的未来都非常光明。我很期待我们明年能做些什么。
Very, very politically. You're just such a polished, you know, off the cuff. Did Bryce prepare for any of this? I don't have an off mode. I don't have an off switch for this. It's just I just wake up in the morning and I'm just in politician mode. Still one of my favorite things. I'll go find the episode.
非常、非常政治化。你真是太圆滑了，你知道的，极其即兴。Bryce 为这一切做过准备吗？我没有“关闭”模式。我没有这方面的关闭开关。我早上醒来就直接进入了政客模式。这仍然是我最喜欢的事情之一。我去把那一期找出来。
It was when you were on CPPcast once and you were talking about all the traveling you were doing. And then Rob asked, one of the hosts of the podcast asked, are you allowed to travel that much? NVIDIA's okay with that? And then you quickly had to transition into an explanation why how all this traveling and work on C++ was invaluable to NVIDIA, and they're a big supporter of the ISO process and all this stuff. And I was just like, you could tell it wasn't prepared at all.
那是你曾经上 CPPcast 节目时，谈到你一直在到处旅行。然后 Rob，播客的主持人之一问，你被允许旅行那么多吗？NVIDIA 对此没有意见吗？然后你迅速过渡到一个解释，说明所有这些旅行和对 C++ 的工作对 NVIDIA 来说是多么无价，他们是 ISO 流程的坚定支持者以及诸如此类的事情。我当时就觉得，你可以看出这完全没有准备。
But it was this like three or four minute sort of, you know, what could have been a very prepared and polished speech that he just off of the cuff, you know, said, and then I was just like, my guy, I wish I had, I'm a decent public speaker, but I cannot just. You're not as good of a bullshitter as I am, is can't just well it's funny what one of the other interesting things that's happened at nvidia um over the past year and i think this is really probably the third thing is not necessarily any of the for me at least not necessarily any of the deliverables that my that the c++ organism atVIDIA has produced, but really more it's the team that we've built. When I joined NVIDIA in 2017,
但这就像是一个持续了三四分钟的演讲，本来可以准备得非常充分和圆润，但他却即兴发挥了出来，然后我就想，我的天哪，我希望我有——我是一个不错的公开演讲者，但我就无法做到这一点。你没有我那么能忽悠，不是吗，就是无法——嗯，有趣的是，过去一年在 NVIDIA 发生另一件有趣的事情，我想这大概是第三件，对我和至少我个人而言，不一定是我在 NVIDIA 的 C++ 组织所产生的任何交付成果，而真正更多的是我们建立的团队。2017 年我加入 NVIDIA 时，
the C++ team was Jared Hobrick, Michael Garland, and Olivier Gouraud. That was it. And NVIDIA was an important player on the C++ committee, but it was not a major player on the C++ committee. And as of right now,
C++ 团队只有贾里德·霍布里克（Jared Hoberock）、迈克尔·加兰（Michael Garland）和奥利维耶·古罗（Olivier Gouraud）。仅此而已。英伟达是 C++ 委员会的重要参与者，但不是主要参与者。而截至目前，
NVIDIA sends the largest number of representatives to the committee. We're very deeply involved to the committee. Um, uh, we are, you know, we're, we're very deeply involved in the committee and, and, and more importantly within the company, um, there's a very strong commitment to standard C plus plus, and also other languages like, um, standard Fortran. And that commitment is not just for our own purposes. We understand that it's important for these languages to thrive in general because they're the basis of computing on our platforms. And so we first and foremost care about what's good for the language and what's good for us in particular is secondary. And that sort of philosophy has been adopted at a very high level within the company. So when I started at NVIDIA, our commitment to standard C++ and our dedication to doing what was good for standard C plus plus was sort of like a gorilla movement that was up
NVIDIA 向委员会派出了数量最多的代表。我们非常深入地参与到委员会的工作中。呃，我们，你知道的，我们非常深入地参与委员会的工作，而且，更重要的是，在公司内部，有一种对标准 C++ 以及其他语言（如标准 Fortran）的非常坚定的承诺。这种承诺不仅仅是为了我们自己的目的。我们明白，这些语言的普遍繁荣非常重要，因为它们是我们平台上计算的基础。因此，我们首先关心的是对语言有利的事情，而对我们特别有利的事情则是次要的。这种理念在公司的高层得到了采纳。所以当我刚开始在 NVIDIA 工作时，我们对标准 C++ 的承诺以及我们致力于做对标准 C++ 有利事情的决心，有点像是一场游击运动，
in the Hills. Um, uh, but now like the gorillas have like taken the Capitol, um, and are like in power. Is this a, is this a politically insensitive, uh, analogy? We're going to get canceled. Um, there are many potentially problematic things about what I just said, but I think it's fine. I think it's fine.
在山里活动。呃，但现在，游击队已经占领了国会山，并且掌握了权力。这是一个政治上不敏感的比喻吗？我们要被取消了。呃，我刚才说的话有很多潜在的问题，但我认为没关系。我认为没关系。
Yeah. But really, like, a large part of our philosophy on the committee is that any large company like NVIDIA that is contributing to a standard, you know, your first priority should be doing what's good for the standard and building goodwill in the community. It really comes down to stewardship. And that's one of the reasons why NVIDIA is okay
是的。但实际上，我们在委员会理念中的很大一部分是，任何像 NVIDIA 这样为标准做出贡献的大公司，你的首要任务应该是做对标准有利的事情，并在社区中建立善意。这实际上归结为管理（stewardship）。这也是 NVIDIA 能够接受的原因之一
with me spending so much of my time running library evolution. Probably 60 to 70% of my time is spent running library evolution and sharing other standards committees. I chair a number of other committees like the inclusive, I don't chair but I'm the project editor for the inclusive terminology guidelines for the US national body. I now am the convener for the vocabulary group for JTC1 and for like two other related vocabulary groups. And you like none of that has like a direct, none of that can directly be linked to like revenue at video. Um, but, uh,
我花这么多时间运行图书馆演进（Library Evolution）。我大约 60% 到 70% 的时间都花在运行图书馆演进和主持其他标准委员会上。我还主持其他几个委员会，比如包容性，我不担任主席，但我美国国家机构包容性术语指南的项目编辑。我现在是 JTC1 词汇小组以及其他两个相关词汇小组的召集人。你知道，这些都没有直接联系，没有一个可以直接与 NVIDIA 的收入挂钩，但是，
you know, if, if nobody invests in those things, then they're, they're just gonna, you know, wither away. Um, somebody has to invest in, in doing the, the, the, the maintenance, and somebody has to invest in, you know, handling all the logistics and the planning of organizing these standards committees. And we should say it's not just NVIDIA. There's a coalition of companies that, you know, which is sort of interesting, you know, when you're talking about... Not just companies, a coalition of companies and individuals. And individuals and national bodies, yeah.
你知道，如果没有人投资这些事情，那么它们就会枯萎消亡。必须有人投资于维护工作，必须有人投资于处理组织这些标准委员会的所有物流和规划。我们应该说，不仅仅是 NVIDIA。有一个公司联盟，你知道，当你谈论……不仅仅是公司，还有公司和个人的联盟。还有个人和国家机构，是的。
Some very motivated individuals. I won't mention him by name because I think he would not want me to call him out. But there is a certain French individual who is a freelancer and has made very substantial contributions to the committee over the years. And I say that not just that he writes a lot of papers, but he writes papers and he takes on a lot of leadership roles. And he doesn't just write papers that interest him. He writes papers that nobody else is writing, but that everybody agrees needs to be written. And, you know, we have a lot of people like that and it's, you know,
一些非常有动力的人。我不会点名说出他的名字，因为我觉得他不会希望我点名。但有一位特定的法国个人，他是一名自由职业者，多年来对委员会做出了非常实质性的贡献。我说这话不仅是因为他写了很多论文，还因为他写论文并承担了许多领导角色。而且他写的不只是他感兴趣的论文。他写的是其他人没有写、但大家都一致认为需要写的论文。而且，你知道，我们有很多这样的人，而且，
there's nobody paying some of these folks to do this. Some of these people are just doing it in their free time. But, you know, that's how, that's how open standards and open source tends to work. Yeah. Which in some ways it's unfortunate. It would be better if we had a model where everybody who was doing this work could have it be a part of their official job and get paid for it. I'm very fortunate that I'm one of the people who is actually have a job where literally this is what I'm paid to do, but that's not the case for everybody. I mean, it's slowly changing. I mean, we're definitely not at the point where you can click a button on GitHub and that funds you to go to like a C++ committee meeting. But one of the podcasts I listen to is called ChangeLog, and it's about open source.
没有人付钱给其中一些人来做这件事。其中一些人只是利用他们的空闲时间在做。但是，你知道，这就是开放标准和开源的工作方式。是的。在某些方面，这很不幸。如果我们能有一种模式，让所有做这项工作的人都能将其作为他们正式工作的一部分并获得报酬，那就更好了。我很幸运，我是那些真正拥有这份工作、字面意思就是付钱让我做这件事的人之一，但并非所有人都是如此。我的意思是，这种情况正在慢慢改变。我的意思是，我们绝对还没有达到那种可以在 GitHub 上点击一个按钮就能资助你去参加 C++ 委员会会议的地步。但我听的一个播客叫 ChangeLog，是关于开源的。
And they talk about sort of the open source funding models and GitHub sponsors, like GitHub's doing a ton of great work and they're sort of adopting like different Patreon models for individuals and companies to basically like fund open source work. And there are now like way more than a handful of folks that are basically get paid their full-time jobs is working on open source projects. And completely randomly, but not completely randomly, because you talked about the insights inclusive terminology document. This is both a interesting anecdote and a call to action for people whenever they're correcting someone. Please give an explanation, like a brief explanation or a link, because for a couple months now in one video or a couple videos I used in in uh pro like a live coding on a youtube video I used the function name for the solution at the end of it because I would
他们谈到了开源资助模式以及 GitHub 赞助商之类的内容，GitHub 做了大量出色的工作，他们正在为个人和公司采用不同的 Patreon 模式来基本上资助开源工作。现在有远超少数的人，他们的全职工作基本上就是靠从事开源项目获得报酬。这完全是随机的，但也不完全是随机的，因为你谈到了包容性术语文档的见解。这既是一个有趣的轶事，也是对人们在纠正别人时的行动呼吁：请给出解释，比如简短的解释或链接，因为在过去的几个月里，我在一个视频或几个视频中，在 YouTube 视频的实时编码中，我在最后使用了一个解决方法的函数名，因为我会展示解决方案一、二、三、四，然后最后的那个我称之为最终解决方案（final solution），我不确定你是否甚至知道。是的。是的。我收到了前几条评论。我不该笑，但我懂。我明白我们要往哪里去。是的。我也理解为什么你不会注意到这一点。我猜有一群人跟我一样并不知道。问题是，我收到的前几条评论说，视频很棒，但是“最终解决方案”这个函数名让我觉得很不舒服。或者他们只是以
show like solution one two three four and then the final one I would call final solution and I'm not sure if even you're aware. Yeah. Yeah. And I got like the first couple comments. I shouldn't laugh, but yeah, I can understand. I see where we're going with this. Yeah. And I also understand why you wouldn't have picked up on this. My guess is that there's a bunch of folks that don't know similar to me. And the thing is, is the first couple comments that I got were that like great video, but like the Final Solution function name rubs me the wrong way. Or they just said it
非常轻描淡写的方式说出来。我以为他们只是说这是一个糟糕的函数名，不可否认，把一个函数命名为最终解决方案或仅仅是解决方案都是糟糕的函数名。它们什么也没说明。所以我当时就想，是的，有道理。没有回复。然后我收到了第三或第四条评论，说，视频很棒，真的很喜欢这些深度探讨。唯一的问题是，作为犹太人，我发现我对“最终解决方案”（Final Solution）感到有点不舒服。即便如此，我第一次读到它时还是觉得很奇怪，像，为什么？
very nondescriptly. And I thought that they just meant it was a bad function name, which admittedly calling a function final solution or just solution are both bad function names. They don't say anything. And so I just was like, yeah, that's a good point. Didn't respond to it. And then the third or fourth comment that I got said, great video, really love these deep dives. Only problem is, is that as a Jewish person, I, I find I'm a little bit uncomfortable with Final Solution. And even still, I was still thinking like the first time I read it, I was like, that's odd. Like why?
我知道这是一个糟糕的函数名。他们难道不在加拿大学校里教纳粹大屠杀吗？他们绝对教过。但是，如果他们教过“最终解决方案”是纳粹用来指代那个事件的另一个名字，我要么不记得了，要么当时没教。所以在想完“他指出自己是犹太人这很奇怪，我懂，这是个糟糕的函数名”之后，我心想，等一下，也许所有人说这话都有别的原因。我谷歌了一下“最终解决方案”。
I know it's a bad function name. Do they not like teach the Holocaust in like Canadian schools? They definitely do. But I, if they taught that thing that final solution is another name that the nazis used to refer to that um i either don't remember it or that wasn't taught and so after thinking like that's weird that he's pointing out that he's jewish like i get it it's a bad function name and then i was like wait a second maybe all these people are saying it for another reason. So I Google final solution.
果不其然，第一个结果是一个维基百科页面，讨论了这就是纳粹使用的术语。所以这绝对是——我知道有这样一种说法，即向压迫者或整个社会解释他们经历过的事情，不是受压迫群体的责任，我们知道他们在经历什么。但如果能直接……我有三四个评论，却没有领会到。甚至在我最后领会到的时候，也是含蓄的，我回复那个人说，哦天哪，非常感谢。就像，我以后一定会避免这种情况。这很有趣。因为，我收到过好几次这个评论，我完全不知道。我真的完全不知道，而且
Sure enough, the first hit is a Wikipedia page talking about how this is the term that the Nazis use. So it is definitely I know there's a whole thing about like, it's not on the oppressed group to explain to their oppressors, or, you know, society at large, we know what they're going through. But it would have been just amazing.. Like I got three or four comments and like, didn't pick up on it. Even, even in the final time when I picked up on it, it was like implicit and all like I was, I responded to the person and said, Oh my goodness, thank you so much. Like, I'll definitely avoid this in the future. It's funny. Cause like, I've got this comment a few times and like, I had no idea. I just had no idea and
它与这样一个事实混淆了：无论它是否具有其他语义，它实际上就是一个糟糕的函数名。所以无论如何，我的看法是，我很高兴被纠正，但在未来，无论是针对 YouTube 视频还是其他内容，不要只是说这让你感到不舒服，如果它——我不是说，也许有些时候解释并不好，但如果有人只是链接了维基百科上的“最终解决方案”，我四个月前或三个月前就能学到这一点了。无论如何，我不确定你有什么想法。但我只是觉得，是的，我，我的意思是，我确实花了一分钟才反应过来，但我本来不会花那么长时间的，嗯，是的，别——是的，我不确定这是否在洞察文档中，但也许
it was conflated with the fact that it is actually just a bad function name regardless of it having some other semantic meaning and so anyways my thing is is that like I was super happy to be corrected but in the future folks whether it's on a YouTube video or something don't just say that it makes you uncomfortable if it like I'm not, maybe there's times that it's not great to explain, but like, I would have learned this, um, like four months ago or three months ago if someone had just linked the Wikipedia final solution. Anyways, I'm not sure if you have thoughts. Uh, but I just, I thought it was, yeah, I, um, I mean, it did take me a minute to, to, to, to get there, but I, it would not have taken me quite that long um yeah don't yeah i'm not sure if that's in the i'm not sure if that's in the insights document but uh maybe
值得添加，我不认为这需要放进去，因为我认为这不太可能会出现——就像，该文档是一套指南，用于确定，你知道的，比如文档中列出的术语，所有术语都在附录中。而该文档的正文是定义什么是带有负面含义的术语，以及如何识别它们，如何着手减轻它们的影响，以及如何迁移它们等等，因此并非所有东西都需要列在那里。我不认为——通常我们列出某事物的标准是需要有先例，所以我有一个详尽的电子表格，我查看了 20 其他不同的包容性术语和技术指南，比如谷歌有一个，IETF 有一个，W3C 有一个，所有这些其他组织都有一个。我只是把每个术语都在那里交叉引用。
worth adding i don't i don't think that that would need to go in because i think it's unlikely that that would come up uh like like the the correct the document is a set of guidelines for how to determine whether, you know, like the terms listed in the document, all the terms are in an annex. And that annex is examples of terms. And the actual body of the document is defining what are terms with negative connotations and like how do you identify them and how should you go about mitigating them and how do you migrate away from them etc um uh and so not everything needs to be listed there um i i do not think like usually our criterion for listing something is that there needs to be prior art so like i have an extensive spreadsheet where I've looked at 20 different other inclusive terminology and tech, you know, guidelines like, you know, Google has one, IETF has one, W3C has one, you know, like all these other organizations have one. And I just like have every term, you know, cross listed there.
所以我可以去查找，哦，你想讨论添加的这个术语，嗯，它出现在这另外三个文档中。而且我知道，比如“最终解决方案”并没有出现在任何其他文档中，因为它不是——我认为这不是我在任何标准文档中遇到过的事情。我也许还可以，我们也可以搜索。
And so I can go look up like, oh, this term that you want to like discuss adding, well, it appears in these three other documents. And like, I know like final solution doesn't appear in any of those other documents because it's not like, I think it's not a thing that I've come across in any standards documents. I could also, you know, we could also search.
我们有一些工具可以让我们在技术标准中进行搜索，看看我们是否能找到任何命中结果。但是，是的，当然，如果它确实出现了，如果它出现在技术标准中，我肯定会主张我们将它添加到术语列表中。但是，是的，这是一个有趣的问题，即你什么时候决定添加某些东西。我不认为我们会主动添加东西。
We have some tools that allow us to search across tech standards to see whether we get hits for anything. But yeah, certainly if it did appear, if it appeared in like a tech standard, I would definitely, you know, advocate for us adding it to the list of terms. But yeah, it's an interesting question when, when you decide to add something. I don't think that we add things, um, proactively like that.
或者至少我们过去没有这样主动添加过任何东西。我刚刚在 GitHub 上搜索了“final solution”，在代码中获得了 8,000 个命中结果，Java 是表现最差的，C++ 排在第二位。不过这些可能更多地说明了它的流行程度。我将稍微修改一下我关于不采取主动步骤的说法。即使在现实中没有现成的有问题的术语被使用的案例，如果你能合理地想象在哪些情况下可能会使用该术语，即使今天没有使用，你也可能会想要将其列出。实际上，你知道，我会想要去更详细地查看你在 GitHub 搜索中的那些命中结果。这不是，现在我们有点进入了我评估一个术语是否应该列入我们的指南时所做的研究过程。人们可能会对此感到惊讶，但包容性术语指南中列出的每个术语都经过了广泛的研究——进行了广泛的研究和广泛的讨论，因为我们
Um, or at least we haven't added anything proactively like that in the past. Um, I just did a search on GitHub for final solution and it got 8,000 hits across code, Java being the worst offender, C++ being in second. Those probably just say more about the popularity of it though. I'm going to slightly modify what I said about not taking steps proactively. If, even if there's not an existing, like, cases of a problematic term being used in the wild, if you could reasonably imagine circumstances in which that term could be used, even if it's not used today, then you'd probably want to list it. And actually, you know, I would want to go and look in more detail at those hits on your GitHub search. This isn't, now we're sort of getting into this research process that I do when I'm evaluating whether a term should be listed in our guidelines. And it may surprise people to learn, but every term that's listed in the inclusive terminology guidelines has been like extensively researched, like extensively researched and extensively discussed because we,
想要了解现实世界中的实际使用情况。我们还想了解不同受影响群体对此有何感受。因此，知道 GitHub 上有 8,000 个命中结果是一回事，但我想看的是，模式是什么？所以你说其中很多在 Java 中。
we want to understand what the actual usage is like in the wild. And we also want to understand like how different like impacted groups that feel about it. And so knowing that there's 8,000 hits on GitHub is one thing, but like what I would want to look at is like, what's like, what's the pattern there? So you said a lot of them are in Java. Well,
所以实际上我看到的是，Python 在列表中的排名非常低。我觉得这很奇怪，因为我以为它会大致对应最流行的语言。但我随后意识到，我输入它时只是作为一个单词“final solution”，没有下划线。这对应于驼峰命名法（camel case），而不是蛇形命名法（snake case）。
so actually what I was, what I saw is actually Python was really low on the list. And I was like, that's odd because I was figuring it would sort of map to the most popular languages. But then I realized I had typed it just as a single word, final solution, no underscore. And that's, that corresponds to camel case, not snake case.
当我把它换成蛇形命名法时，我又得到了 3,000 个命中结果。然后 Python 排在第一位。C++ 排在第二位。所以我的想法是这样的。这可能就是——真正影响我的决定的因素将是这个问题：所有这些使用都符合某种模式吗？比如可能会想到的模式是“final solution”，一种常见的命名模式，例如在竞技编程中——所有这些使用都出现在相同的模式中吗，比如在
And then when I switched it to snake case, I got another 3,000 hits. And then Python was number one. And C++ is number two. So here's what I would think. Here's probably what would, you know, like the thing that would really factor in my decision would be this question. Are all of these uses falling in some pattern? And like the pattern that might come to mind is final solution, a common naming pattern, example in competitive coding like are all of these uses coming up like in the same like like you know in like solutions to
竞技编程问题的解决方案中？因为如果是这样，那么是的，将这个术语列出来可能是有意义的，因为如果它正在成为特定领域的专业术语，我们肯定希望在它甚至进入标准世界之前就把它切断。所以，是的，我真的必须去查看并更多地了解这种用法。嘿，既然 GitHub 正在改进他们的代码搜索，我为此感到非常兴奋，这真的是太棒了，
competitive coding problems because if so then then yeah it would probably make sense to list the term because if it's something that's that's becoming a term of art in a particular field, then we definitely want to cut that off before it would even enter the world of standards. So yeah, I'd really have to go and look and understand more about that usage. And hey, now that GitHub is in the process of making their code search like better, which I'm so excited about, that's, that's really excellent. Um, it will be substantially easier to go and do these sorts of things. Although I say that, but the thing that GitHub's code search actually used to be okay at was searching for like function names. The thing that it was really bad at is for
去做这类事情将会容易得多。话虽如此，GitHub 的代码搜索过去实际上还算可以的一点是搜索函数名。它真正非常糟糕的是搜索
searching for like anything that's not just like alphanumeric, like, you know, like searching for like something that has like symbols in it as well. You know, like operators, et cetera, or like a function signature, things like that. Yeah, I can't. It doesn't really look like there's much of a pattern just on sort of first. It looks like a mix of like homework seems to be like the number one thing um which makes sense and then but that actually that actually might be sufficient like if it um well perhaps that would mean that that's not something that should go into an inclusive term into the insights inclusive terminology guideline but maybe that's
任何不仅仅是字母数字的东西，比如搜索带有符号的东西，比如运算符等，或者函数签名等等。是的，我不能。仅凭第一印象，似乎并没有什么规律。它看起来像是作业的混合体似乎是第一大类，这说得通，但实际上这可能就足够了——如果它——嗯，也许这意味着那不应该进入包容性术语——进入洞察包容性术语指南，但也许这
just something that um you know that some CS curriculum guidelines should keep in mind. There's some advent of code and competitive programming stuff. It looks like a lot of this is people solving some school problem, doing homework or something. So maybe, yeah. Maybe college professors just, like, should take a note that maybe don't have people call. No, I'm sure it's not even, it's probably not even the profs. It's just an organic thing that, like, came up if you got a couple different solutions and then but um you know it's something that like if you're a professor and you have students that are submitting like like you can just mention it to them right right right you know like it's it's far it's far better for us to solve
只是一些计算机科学（CS）课程指南应该牢记的事情。有一些 Advent of Code 和竞技编程的内容。看起来这里面很多都是人们在解决学校问题、做作业什么的。所以也许，是的。也许大学教授应该注意一下，也许不要让人们去调用——不，我敢肯定甚至都不是教授。这只是一种有机的事情，如果你有几个不同的解决方案，就会出现这种情况，但是，你知道，如果你是一位教授，并且你的学生提交了类似的代码，你可以向他们提及，对吧，你知道的，
these terminology issues before they become a problem yeah um like we we i said earlier that like we don't want to like proactively youactively, you know, add terms to this document. But that doesn't mean that we don't want to proactively address the problem. as being problematic in an inclusive terminology guideline, because we do such a good job of thinking about the language that we're using, that there is no sort of existing art of problematic terms. Obviously, we're never going to get there. But, but, you know as early as possible about uh being cautious about the language that they use yeah yeah no i totally agree all right we're close we're approaching the 30 minute mark and uh we haven't we've done my 2021 retrospective what about your 2021 retrospective stay tuned next week for part two thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have
我们在这些术语成为问题之前解决它们要好得多。是的，就像我们之前说的，我们不想主动向这个文档中添加术语。但这并不意味着我们不想主动解决这个问题。作为包容性术语指南中的问题，因为我们在思考所使用的语言方面做得太好了，所以不存在有问题的术语的现有艺术。显然，我们永远不会达到那个阶段，但是，你知道，越早越好，要对他们使用的语言保持谨慎。是的，是的，我完全同意。好吧，我们快到了，我们快接近 30 分钟大关了，而且我们还没有——我们完成了我的 2021 年回顾。你的 2021 年回顾呢？请收看下周的第二部分。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家
a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
度过美好的一天！本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。